[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for the Doctor Who special for where we
judge this new doctor and go he's not
like the last doctor he's not David he's
a different I'm comparing new flavor oh
gosh they're doing different things I
have to adjust do you guys like him I I
don't know we'll find out I'm excited
we'll be honest I'll let you know if we
don't want
Christmas specials a doctor especially
can go either way so definitely be
honest about anyway yeah sorry for being
late guys we have Christmas I'm sick
still recovering might hearing my voice
a little bit but you know what's making
me feel great the fact that so many of
you have bought our real rejects
exclusive Doctor Who t-shirt here's a
closeup for you on screen yeah it's a
bunch of quotes from the doctors from
the 9th to the 14th technically one of
my favorite chirs and in December it
became I believe our second or third
most Soul Church all year and we've
already had a fantastic year fantastic
fantastic so thank you guys so so so
much if you want to pick yourself up a
shirt Link in the description box and
pin comment John they should leave a
like they should leave a like that is it
should subscribe and hit the
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for Doctor Who in Spring is
over absolutely and if you keep ignoring
those notifications until time and then
full link
through highlights down and then hey if
you want to get the full length
experience sync up and see everything
that doesn't make these reaction
highlights go to patreon.com the real
reject grab your own copy along it's a
watch along got to let them let them
know some people get
misund let's watch
it once upon a time late on Christmas
Eve a stranger came to the church on
Ruby Ro Ruby Road
The Strangers she carried in her arms
the most precious gift of all Jesus a
newborn child a baby girl then she
slipped she left her daughter on the
steps of the church that a real baby the
child was taken in and they named her
Ruby after the place where she was found
is Ruby the new companion maybe we'll
see or at least the Christmas companion
as for the mother she was never seen
again until until that night a time
traveler came to call hello handsome a
traveler known as the doctor is he
crying he is crying he was that touched
by it single tear no babies should be
alone at Christmas so this doctor is
going to be very sensitive yeah Ruby
named after Ruby Road that's where I was
found 19 years ago so you were a
foundling were fostered by Carla who
then went on to adoption is that right
who's that woman she looks familiar in
the old days foundlings were left
Without a Trace now we really can work
with DNA so that is true Mor is here
you've taken your sample and we're going
to use it to help track your genetic
Heritage a lot of people do this on
their own to be able to trace your birth
mother or birth father provided they've
also done a 23 in me and even if we do
make
contacts they might not want to be found
it's like
Gremlins if we did find someone just the
truth no whoa yeu Christ
prankster ouch
ow damn three weeks
later I don't know I think it's just
dead give you son
Willie this is a really musically
inclined episode yeah look at that
lighting too
there he is oh my man look at that Kilt
enjoy yourself duck oh she's just drawn
to him for his sexual dance moves his
free open energy surprised these
Gremlins have been around for weeks and
he hasn't noticed them yet oh golly or
maybe that's why he's there careful
thank you but you were just over there
health and safety Gonic division
does that happen to you a lot knocking
things over he knows I'm just clumsy no
no you're not no one's just clumsy it's
worse than that Merry
Christmas it's worse than that it's
Christmas telling you there's a
whirlwind about about look and who's in
the center of
me I would love it if Jonathan major
just gets into that
taxi then immediately takes off down the
road whenever I see any type of taxi
service down
yep oh
yeah oh you better Sonic Screwdriver
that speaking of what does his new
screwdriver look like oh there it
is oh my god of
course can't hear that oh my God you're
right
pram at midnight what does pram mean
walking your baby okay it's my
shopping I'm going to have to report
this name the doctor occupation not a
[Music]
doctor myself address that
blue now if you don't I just got Snowman
and I would like to go home so if you
haven't seen Doctor Who there you go
guys that's that's everything you know
the doctor you could just start here
she's going to see us who is your
girlfriend when when you ask her to
marry you on Christmas Day how do you
know that masic screwdriver just meant
ping what was detecting a Two karat
diamond in your pocket but how do you
know she'll say yes knew you just
couldn't wait and that is why she loves
you I like him joh we love him he's a
man of the
people damn he just straight up took off
in front of this guy she says yes it's a
Christmas miracle so so wow by just the
knowledge she'll say yes Hees doesn't
even care that this Tardis just vanished
before his eyes police call box that was
Santa Claus isn't it your birthday love
oh it is yeah it was a Christmas Eve
baby ah yeah police box I haven't seen
one on the Streets of London for 50
years and I don't not the groceries has
she encountered the doctor
before not the eggs I like the new rose
yeah Ruby Rose that's what I keep
thinking of every time I hear her name
we're having a baby no way you kidding
she's coming around with the baby right
now it's been years since we fostered
one this young I can't remember how to
put this thing together now you're
screwing it up she's called Lulu Bell
a oh an absolutely terrible name it
awful sorry for all the Lulu Bell fans
of Doctor Who Dr Hulu Bell just
alienating half of your
audience tolerance what I like to take a
snap
smile whoa what a transition I want a
Polaroid I'm leaving you in charge rule
number one don't lose the baby I'll try
my best the theme the baby's going on an
adventure there is no trace of your mom
or dad and now the show is being
cancelled because of you how about you
call like another day yeah not on
Christmas freaking Eve isn't that
unusual though there's not a single
trace anywhere mean in the whole wide
world my mother's never left it's not
that simple you've been having any bad
luck recently whoa holy [__] what the
hell is going on ever since that day
it's never stopped I've been hit I fell
off a boat on dry land what she's going
to get murdered yeah and I can't help
thinking it all comes back to when I met
you your bad luck you're a curse having
bad luck recently but I I just keep ding
things I knew it tell me how I can make
it stop she's about to die oh she about
to die oh she's about to die can't avoid
have you ever wondered why the murder
rate is so low oh and the accident rate
is so high murdered by a Christmas
tree happy
birthday
yeah
no do they eat
babies I think they just kidnapped it I
don't think they would do a baby
eating that'd be a little dark for a
Christmas
[Music]
special this it like a fun well-paced
Whimsical episode yeah what the hell
where are
you got a little Santa
hat
give me that my
baby he's got your baby you may not have
a birth mom but you will be a mom to
this baby yes you will you will protect
you will be a mom for everyone you and
the
doctor what the hell are you
doing a l in the sky and you thought
yeah I'll give that go
babe he's
athletic loving the outfit
too look at them sneaks Ruby Sunday
hello Ruby Sunday and it's a Sunday
right now that's a
coincidence hold oh right right wait
wait wait cuz I uh spent a lot of time
hanging off things I invented these
gloves intelligent gloves one each
should work put on are they just regular
gloves they're Ghost Protocol gloves
gloves are kind of super ktic transfer
of
mass oh no oh no they are magic gloves
the glove takes all my weights real
inventor let me get some of those yeah
all the mass and density and mavity
exists in the glove
mity oh we got a thread where what's up
there goblins do you know why they call
them goblins no cuz they like to gobble
you up and this want to gobble up the
baby they do want to eat the baby it's
true look at that I knew I should have
read up on my Goblin history before
watching this it's okay we're all a
little ignorant toward Goblin history oh
it's like Super
Mario some of the best levels in Super
Mario
[Music]
3 what a random choice for
your Christmas
episode like a a slight Time Bandits
Vibe here can't believe a single thing
that's happening it's my birthday
they're going to eat lul what time's
dinner no but it's Lulu's birthday such
a brilliant
name doctor in for the safe Dr Lulu
coincidence is what makes the baby tasty
that's how these goblins work chance and
coincidence and
luck these goblins are time Riders they
can surf the waves of
time they caused my accident were they
trying to kill me no no no no no if you
walk through a day without any bad luck
that's fine but if you have lots of
accidents it stitches you in it
complicated and naughty yeah tasty all
of it leading up to a baby on Christmas
Eve oh so like buttering
marinating the same birthday as yours
with the bedroom that is high up in the
sky all the more convenient for Goblin
sh that tapestry is
gorgeous what is a coincidence but a
form of accident it's a great great line
what is a coincidence but a form of
accident why are you an expert in time
traveling
goblins they are not Time Travelers Time
Travelers are great like the best like
wow
wait how did you do that I spent a long
hot summer with Harry hini oh my God yes
call call backs to did we see that
episode yes yes of course but research
that put it in the edit it's in the
extended publications of Doctor
Who a goblin
door wrong world what is that thing
Sonic Screwdriver screwdriver needs
screws these look B everything a not
There are rules to your Sonic
Screwdriver that's not the doctor who
I've gotten accustomed to that must be
the time for the feast what what time is
it
now two no you really do need a Sonic
that can manipulate wood and and ropes
and stuff this stuff is their version of
wires and electricity so if
we cut the brown wire God ship has the
equivalent
of I like watching him I like watching
him absolutely very capting performer
what's the time three minutes
to fun hurry Barbie and Ken what a fun
pirate ship
[Music]
set who's playing the
music oh my
God
what is happening yes yes they're s
there musical number yep I wonder who
ship this is the Goblin King whoa the
Goblin King in the Hall of the Goblin
King oh how gross oh it's like a dolly
that goes right to its mouth yeah who is
the performer who's the singer yeah who
do they get to do the
voice
no yes Goblin song was not on my bingo
card
[Music]
nope I expect nothing less from
fluctuating visual effects from Doctor
Who yes why stop
singing rocket
Janice this is a musical episode yeah
they should do a full-on musical I would
love it I'm here for
it
yeah thank you so
[Music]
much that's
we
wonder if those either real voices you
reverse intelligent gloves you get heavy
yeah how do we love the glove love the
glove love the glove it's going on the
next version of the shirt love the glove
probably the thing about coincidences Oh
I thought it was like a commentary on
sexual protection oh definitely love the
glove yeah love the glove I am so happy
they gave us a musical number oh yeah
and who is this young fellow when he's
at home hi I'm the doctor last time I
saw a doctor he tried to murder me so
you stay away nah you want them only 3%
left so plug them in are we you safe can
that ship Come Sailing down what do we
do can they get us he doesn't know yet
they only creep into ours and the
edges they're going to burst through
their bad luck accidents that is how
they get us did they cause all accidents
maybe they do oh death trap check everon
the the WN and the plus a word about
furniture killing
machines that are all his companions
yeah it's entire chronology it's Mom's
children it's all the kids that she's
fosted over the years contact all them
yes how much bad luck are you having you
have got the biggest family in the world
what about you uh I've got no one oh
make sure the office s
yeah just so unbothered by it yeah I've
got no this is the doctor hello is she
all right the baby no she's
fine little
chicken hello Lulu Bell I don't think
that's Lulu Bell I think they grabbed
the wrong baby I I've had enough this
has been the worst day ever and it is
Christmas and it's my birthday and it's
just been a disaster no can't be the
worst ever come on you got to see
goblins in the sky I'm sorry I'm sorry
just
um oh she doesn't know about the call
they phoned from the TV show but they
didn't find anything you have this
family yeah I'm sorry darling come here
come
here just ignore those deep rooted
feelings and just deal logically with
what you have
now I was counting when I was out Lulu
Bell is the 33rd child I fostered 33
like Jesus I've got photos have a look
on the fridge they're all there I had
some of them for days some for weeks
some for years the baby's going to be
his new companion doctor speaks baby
it's true no I was uh I was abandoned oh
you were founding just like Ruby not
even bigger
coincidence not so the Goblins plant
this
no don't move don't move don't move move
it's the only rent controlled unit one
cup of tea mus just
one thank you Cherry thank
you go back to your games look at the
ceiling and the window I'm going to
freeze who's going to fix that on
Christmas Eve byebye you need a plaster
screwdriver a absolutely nothing
yeah whoa why' that happen I don't know
what the hell just happened uh maybe we
should sit you down and tell you a
Christmas story huh what' you think Ruby
my old man was Ruby
taken Ruby where's Ruby I'm looking for
your daughter don't be Dar L's not my
daughter I'm fostering her just for a
couple of days no no no no I mean I mean
your daughter Ruby oh what the hell is
happening Ruby you're getting wonderful
right now your daughter I told you this
is Lulu and she's a right old pain on
Christmas Eve oh no who I got nipple
chills are we going to go into an
alternate past where she was just kept
by her mom or something another child
named Ruby I've never had children mate
no you adopted her a foster five or six
kids no no no no you oh my god there was
like 33 right yeah what happened to all
of them how much worse have their lives
gotten your
children oh a life but what's that pizza
place Mentos Pizza it's just me stuck
with my old mom up here in the attic and
I'm busy couldn't have a kid full time
it' be a nightmare wow she's so bitter
this little BR arrives ruining my
holiday just looking forward to it what
happened to all the hopefulness it's all
gone why would I want a daughter when
I'm happy as I am
no then why are you crying wow he like
shot to tears you see
yeah they took the baby they went back
they took the baby the other baby they
took all the babies they can time travel
they cracked the timeline I will fix
this I love the variations in his
delivery yeah the bounciness of
emotionality but then when like the
chips are really down like how serious
he can
get cool
ding
ding oh we were what this oh my
God that's why he was crying cuz he had
it post I we got in a loop we went in a
Time
Loop oh
damn e he probably a lot more agile
without that coat Le just probably
weighing you down
doctor
oh good old
ladder yes Magic
[Music]
glove there's only like 2% battery at
this point I know it'll be just
enough oh he's using the heavy to pull
it down yeah not bad that's
smart wow dude
I love the giant Goblin
King jump and yank it down I have gloves
kind of like that Gore the King right
through
oh I need some ice cream what if it
killed the baby rewind time a little bit
[Music]
more
whoa
interesting
[Music]
whoa killing the Goblin King the king's
like Tethered to the entire ship and
everyone else so that it's just I guess
or or just like the time this this isn't
like what should have happened on the
timeline so I guess it all just like
dissipates to where it's supposed to be
happy birthday
R A it all comes full circle he's her
protector dude it's like fish and chips
in the in their the the yeah like when
Matt Smith met little tiny
uh po snow over
her iglo and then
knock this is the most epic righteous
Christmas
song tackler who is it I don't think we
need to find out but I'm not opposed to
finding out but I don't think we need to
find out what if it's
Rose I don't
know maybe we could be in that timeline
though I don't
know there you
are happy birthday what happened W it
was only like 10 minutes of time that
changed but it felt like a really long
time yeah yeah totally it's an effective
job
something oh is he is he going to go
back now for Mom I brought your mom here
now she's going to explain why she did
this to you she doesn't need the
mom that's the
mom good
shot oh she's saving
her you saved my
life come on my show Merry Christmas
deina MCO is deino Mcall like a real
life personality or something I guess
maybe you look like you've lost a pound
and found a
Sixpence what's wrong just wondering
maybe I'm the bad luck no never and who
is he anyway that man what's his name Dr
what who what do she mean he went back
what sort of doctor did he say a
gynecologist a
prologist Merry Christmas who are you
anyway she passing by I guess she hasn't
had an encounter with the doctor before
he he said I was taken as a baby he said
he went what did he mean he went went
with
Houdini Houdini was like 1900 192s and
then he spoke about time troublers and
then
he she piece it all together Mrs FL did
you see there was a man and he's about
so high and amazing in a big
leather good description what do you
mean it's right behind
you one more musical number come on o
nipple chills again nipple chills
too I feel like she knows that there's
something weird about her performance
there's a glint in her eye yeah who are
you I'm a man of two shirts I'm the
doctor I'm the
doctor new home new
who Mrs FL did you
see the Box thing it just vanished I
don't hate you it was there then it was
wasn't it just disappeared yes a Merry
Christmas [__] she's too used to it stop
making such a
f never seen a tardis before
oh she's got to be somebody something's
up with her are old lady what was her
name Anita Robinson she's
Rose everyone's Rose everyone's Rose
yeah and all ties back
around damn
woohoo
damn I got to say man he'd be looking
fly in those two different shirts he wor
he could use a third shirt though he
could use a third shirt to never forget
the past and the great lines that have
come before him the Lexicon of the many
bars the doctor has spat and woven with
a shirt like the one mwa is gracing upon
his hairy body
with a tardis full of memories oh so
many wonderful memories yes never be
cruel at www.re Nation shop.com we also
got a bunch of other t-shirts over there
as well that I'm sure are flashing upon
the screen right now looks so beautiful
but we're here to celebrate the doctor
people yes and now let's talk about Z
all right John take it away don't make
any black or gay jokes oh goodness I
challenge you I I know you've been
holding it in this entire time and
frankly I don't like that kind of
attitude here on this
channel don't but I'm going to grab my
jacket
it's funnier because you can't you can't
hear the squeak do you
call what do you need there's a spider
in the car what do you mean there's a
spider in the car a spider in the car
I'm the doctor I can't I can get rid of
a spiders cool spiders are our
friends you can go spider I need to find
you another world to live in all right
John while you review Doctor Who because
there's no retakes here
of course
not I'm GNA go kill this
spider okay well uh I guess I'll just
get this thing going
then uh hey guys I really enjoyed that
episode quite a bit actually uh you know
Doctor Who Christmas specials can be hit
or miss as to whether they feel like
Christmas and also just the overall
quality of those episodes can sometimes
be hit or miss and uh you know the the
way in which everything fits into the
amount of time is just a thing that you
know can go either way across all of
Doctor Who Um But Here and Now in a new
age uh I was very chuffed off this
episode I really like the
proportionality of this I thought that
it was a nice uh you know Christmas
adjacent Story I mean you could tell a
story about an orphan and and you know
found family at any point in time but
obviously Christmas is a resonant time
to do that and it is I think a lesser I
was just watching a film called Miracle
On Main Street about a woman who uh you
know through a convoluted series of
events uh you know finds a baby and and
needs to kind of like use the baby to
get out of trouble with the law but then
discovers that she loves the baby and
wants to keep it as her own and raise it
and uh you know I feel like the baby uh
abandoned on the church steps at
Christmas it's a classic image and uh I
thought there was a nice way to jump off
here and to illustrate the backstory of
our new companion but also you know do
it in such a way that complement the
holiday and various tropes of Christmas
stories two black guys in a game man
walk oh good oh good what do you call a
black gay guy flying an
airplane you may need to repeat
everything you said because I wasn't
here for it okay well I really enjoyed
this uh and I don't have any like big
asterisks or qualifiers I feel like
Doctor Who Christmas specials can often
go either way in terms of how christmy
they feel and also just how well they
prioritize time and just the overall
quality of those episodes can be kind of
Hit or Miss and I thought that this
nicely encapsulated aspects of the
holiday but had an appropriately hooy
and Adventure I thought it was a nice
choice to use this it's a lesser known
Christmas Story Trope of like the baby
found on the church steps I was just
recounting an experience I had not two
nights ago watching a Christmas movie
that was predicated on much a similar
setup was all this already said yes wow
this is just very repetitive at this
point oh goodness well anyway what did
you think this is very repetitive
especially for our listeners who are
listening us on Apple and Spotify they
should this video they're probably
should do is repat theity of raing this
this is my first audio I'm listening to
of whoever these guys are yeah and and
it's too much for me this guy left said
something about a spider I don't have
any context there's no video did you did
you encourage the spider to go find a
new home world where it doesn't have to
steal ours no I squashed it then I ate
it like a normal person of course get
that protein maybe get that
protein what do you think of the episode
I liked it I liked it a lot wait wa wait
before you get to that what did the
black guy and the gay guy do in the bar
I don't remember oh damn it they got
along they had a drink and they were
served properly said welcome and they
their bartender everything went
celebrated a nice Christmas friendly no
noticed nobody was any the wiser cuz it
was just another normal
day and uh and you call the black gay
guy flying the airplane a pilot yeah you
racist uh yeah I mean I thought it was a
really good episode I thought it was
really fun and vibrant and exciting it's
cool to get like a different type of
tone cuz it this is technically like
their fourth special in a row right and
each special has felt very different
whereas the other three really did
capture tenant and that's the other
thing I didn't find myself thinking
about tenant at
all right now this very moment yeah we
just did all that with him didn't we we
just had three specials with tenant and
I was very absorbed into what we were
watching um I thought it was actually a
smart call to have have a lot of the
focus be on the on Ruby and and not do
the thing where like they tease it a
little bit throughout where she's having
some little encounters with the doctors
in the background but it's not the the
focus of like who is this guy like the
whole time it's just really the one
incident at the club yeah uh outside of
that it's mainly just focused on Ruby
her life the mystery with her mom um how
funny it would be if it was just that
old lady next door and it's just like
the mystery with her mom and and just
her family life you know and I think
that's usually what makes the best of
the companions when you can get invested
into who they are outside of the doctor
and what their relationship is with the
doctor because I was I was finding
myself just kind of enjoying the
whatever the drama is that she's
experiencing you know like her personal
journey and that duality of identity of
when you you're an adopted kid and yet
there is still that longing for
identification of knowing who your birth
parents are and like why end that
question might linger in your head you
know so there's some people who uh are
fostered or adopted and they don't care
to get to know their birth parents then
there's the other side where you do have
that thing that kind of pokes to the
back of your brain like who was my birth
mom and why did they leave me why didn't
they ultimately want me and it it all
depends on upbringing and blah blah blah
there's a whole bunch of things that can
factor in and I say to all them get over
it yeah get over it be here now right
now in the moment all right you don't
need anybody you don't need anybody
except who you got with you right now
take it from someone who had his
biological and still has one of them
around and yeah so take it from someone
with who was raised by his biological
parents it ain't anything special in
fact half of Us wish we were adopted
yeah you get more Lage mom Christmas was
rough this
year so many things happened and I
didn't get the information I wanted I'm
depressed so uh yeah I I think she's
great and uh as for our new doctor I
thought he was excellent you know like
one thing with with the doctor that you
want to have a kind of that fun but you
also want to have where you can the
gravitas and I wasn't reminded of any of
the previous incarnations other than
like I'm aware that he's a doctor yeah
you know I I still felt like he he
really brought his own he's got his own
flare he's like a black guy from the 70s
in a way all you need to do is give him
an afro he's got the outfit he's all
decked out ready for action you know
what I mean I'm sure we'll go back in
time at some point maybe we'll get dror
with the fro do the
Disco Saturday night doctor he's one fro
away from looking that way man sure I
would love a fro doctor a black man and
a gay guy walk into a bar and they both
have an afro what year is it the 70s
where time of progression and sexual
exploration was at its at its
revolutionary time yes yeah yeah yeah it
was neither as Progressive as it is now
but it was also much more galvanized in
terms of just yeah like the doctor trip
this episode yeah yeah absolutely I
would love a doctor who Acid Trip you
kidding me oh my God what would the
doctor see what is the doctor's ego
death experience like I know right let's
do that so uh but he he's he's wonderful
he's he's really wonderful yeah he's
really really gripping to watch and I
was wondering what yeah they they've
said that like this is quote like the
healed doctor and I was like okay what
is that going to look like what is that
going to do for the character what is
the character going to have to you know
grapple with and they they do at least
touch on the Timeless child thing I'm
adopted um but yeah I don't know just
just the way and I mean that'll be part
of the fun of the series moving forward
into the actual thick of the season is
kind of seeing yeah okay who is this guy
now what uh you know elements will
separate his take on the character and
we get a good sense for just what his
characterization is here which I found
yeah very appealing both in the fun and
bouncy side as well as when you know
he's like wrecked when you know it's
clear that like time has been Rewritten
like I bought just how much he cares
about that and so you know age we've had
these doctors multiple now that have you
know so much bagg
and it's kind of nice to be without the
baggage a little bit and I'm sure we'll
gain new baggage as we go listen
listeners on on Apple and Spotify need
not worry about what's happening right
now but I I'm just grabbing a hard drive
here guys I I desperately need it and uh
you explain to listeners it's tough
tending to two different platforms
tending to multiple platforms at once
you know what I mean and uh we are
always constantly doing so because I
mean we've got this on YouTube but
there's also patreon there's the podcast
there wa's need to do extra pluging John
um oh sorry please leave it to the
professionals a default I just assume
you need your dongle at all times well
there's still a sense of loneliness to
him that you kind of need yeah that was
one of my concerns too of like the heal
doctor of oh but that part of the the
baggage is part of what makes the doctor
sure and I don't feel like it's
completely eliminated I don't you know
like even though this is all a bunch of
made up mumbo jumbo a guy who's lived
forever um or or not a
guy it's both it's the it's a them it's
a them I need to adjust they they are
they I need to adjust my my framing on
it it's nonbinary the doctor's been a
bit of everybody yeah yeah I need to I
need to adjust the way I
speak does the doctor even identify as a
he I keep saying he I don't even know
presenting male at the moment but yeah
that's a good point we didn't really
do the pronouns this time well we should
have yeah oh well surprisingly less
woke the other ones uh at least in terms
of of like directly cluing you into the
message I mean you know there's a lot of
diverse casting in here um you know
there's at least you know several Black
cast members a trans actress in here at
least uh you know
multiple
actors T DAV turning to the camera going
hey I got something to tell you what's
the th here it
is and if you don't like it tough I'm
talking to you audience I'm talking to
you bigots out there and or people who
just get really upset about popular
entertainment I got something to say
this episode here it is yeah so listen
up get your keyboards out cuz you're
going to be miffed at this one Whatever
We got people talking and leaping uh
simultaneously I enjoyed it all though
the mavity of the situation ah way to
bring it back John um
so this's face you're not going to get
any of
this this type of disorganization in any
other Doctor Who review out there the
most madc one yeah like the doctor when
he's trying to like have a conversation
while the tars is going man I just to do
it all we're going to take the angle of
the of the review in that port and I'm
just going to tilt it all around like
it's crazy what do you think of a sonic
screwdriver oh yeah it looks like a like
an ergonomic mouse or something uh you
know I'm open to it it's I mean I barely
once he pulled it out the first time I
was like oh that's an interesting shape
and then the rest of is he talking about
I'm talking about his doctor uh but no I
I
think Dr donga uh I think it's cool I
didn't you know it's different obviously
I'm going to have to like quote get used
to it but like after the first time I
saw it I was pretty much like yeah it's
the Sonic here we go you know like it's
it's not shaped like a screwdriver as
much as it was before but that's fine I
don't really
care I don't really care yeah some
people cool I don't know some people get
really hung up on that stuff and and I
haven't heard any opinions about totally
fine if you're hung up on it I'm not
here to change your opinion I am I'm to
say that as long as it is lightweight
and he can carry it around and do the
exact same thing as Sonic doesn't really
matter this magical Gizmo that opens all
doors except the wooden ones that's an
interesting rule that always been the
rule cuz L saw screwdrivers able to do
anything create like force field Shields
yeah you I I believe that it is at least
a rule that it doesn't manipulate like
Organics like wood all right so if like
if this whole ship is made of wood then
like okay we might be screwed um yeah I
like his outfits uh it's very he's he
feels just like a
dude like more so than anyone like Matt
Smith was probably the closest it came
he still felt like Larger than Life Matt
felt like a cool Professor that like
still felt like an
alien I guess man Smith but he also
looks kind of like it I was gonna say he
felt like the professor that
would that you know like uh adult
college students would be sleeping with
sure yeah the hip young Professor whose
bow ties are
cool yeah totally totally sure I could
see it whereas this guy seems like the
most Young and the most yeah a guy but I
don't mind I don't mean I I don't mind
that I still felt like when he's in the
full-on suit I was still like is the
doctor though you know well the doctor's
more about like how you carry yourself
sure and the cool things you say he
having a coat super sensitive he's a
super sensitive doctor and the doctor
lately has been like very hardened MH
and I think
by uh breaking him down into the heal
doctor has allowed him to be more on the
empathetic side as when you say heal
doctor you're probably just like hey
he's going be all smiles all the time
yeah and everything's good uh but he's
more he's touched more you know like he
was crying like all the time in this
episode you cry twice you're crying all
the time he's crying like nonstop
beginning to end when he's dancing in
the club when he first sees the goblin
when he's playing with the Rope he's
just crying just the crybaby
doctors Doctor Cry Baby blah
[Music]
blah Dr
boohoo that's right boy that's right
that's what I want from my doctor that's
that's what I want is just the crybaby
doctor but no he's a really sensitive
doctor uh I really like Ruby a lot as
well and she feels again just like a
very three-dimensional character and uh
I like the tethering to her past of how
of how they they showed how that came to
be of the the connection there I thought
that was a nice surprise of how that
came to be
because I thought he was I thought the
beginning was just the beginning like
the way played on mind I thought like
okay he goes there and then he already
knew who she was when we're watching the
story line progress and then find oh
like oh he didn't know we saw was the
end they tarantine of that [__] they did
and they didn't show us the full content
yeah I thought that was really cool of
how of of how they they they misled us
on that the whole time I was like I
thought he I thought he knew who she was
yeah yeah hundo um it it was a nice
special it and it felt very christmy for
the most part and I like how like to
call her Ruby and to be born Christmas
Eve a lot of times Christmas specials
might not even feel like a Christmas
thingy and just felt like Christmas mhm
yeah and I really liked Mom and Grandma
and just their the person you pointed
out the way they shoot the apartment
just makes it feel very engaged point
this out and Lively I like said things
about it I like their little life and
the way it was portrayed really happy to
say those things super great things you
said dude I'm going go back to the
reaction and just watch you say them
over and over yeah and uh and we got
this little
mystery uh I looked up just to see if we
were missing some kind of cameo in uh
Mrs flood but apparently that's a a
mystery that will unfold over the season
as to who she is so uh we didn't
actually miss anything that I know of
although there are at least fan theories
that like oh maybe it's this past
companion or maybe it's a version of
River Song or maybe it's somebody to do
with the master maybe it's this or maybe
it's someone totally new so nobody knows
and it's nice to be just included on a
mystery that's here and now in instead
of some past
Touchstone no I don't know not that
those are bad but you know it's nice to
just be here and now and not be like
damn if I had only spent all my life
watching hundreds and hundreds of back
episodes yeah well overall I thought
that this actually felt different and
I'm excited to see how everything
unfolds and he's got good chemistry with
Ruby yeah which is a really important
Touchstone and I like the goblin we we
talked about the goblins and the fact
that there was music that was a surprise
I loved that they have songs big
surprise yeah and I like the sort of
like time Bandy kind of strangeness of
yeah their floating you know sky ship
and I haven't seen time bden so I don't
get the reference hence I do not like
this now you know pirates in time and
space and flying and all sorts of stuff
but you know uh not that it's a one to
one it's not 100% it's the thing STS
yeah it's like Star Wars Okay and like
The Hobbit because of goblins um but I
like the Goblins I like their their I I
you know it's like we don't really get
to know them a heap ton or there's not
really that big resolve of like ah we
need to Vanquish you or wipe you out or
find you a new home or whatever but like
it I thought I thought the way they
handled it worked and I liked all their
different little Aesthetics and the fact
that you've got the one big guy and and
you know you have mult pull effects like
one thing I think is neat and it kind of
has that similar resonance to like how
they were doing when the Star Wars
sequels were still fresh and you're like
oh man they're doing a little bit of
each they're doing puppetry and CGI and
people and makeup and whatever else and
the Goblins you know clearly there's a
lot of CG there but I thought that they
did nicely to utilize certain practical
effects especially with the Goblin King
and and all that stuff just yeah gave it
this sort of like fun and somewhat even
DeMent
Hensen quality a little bit sort of when
they're in the ship itself yeah the ship
yes yeah yeah yeah that's that's when
they're first on the roof I'm like sure
yeah CU they got to be full
motion little CG guys but yeah I mean
and and I don't begrudge Doctor Who it's
I feel like the legacy of Doctor Who is
like well remember when this started out
they were in like a blackbox theater
with like cardboard you know creature
cut and stuff so like you know any
effect is fine now part of the charm of
Doctor Who is when they have wibbly
wobbly effects yes wibbly wobbly CG
Ouija yeah man uh overall uh solid solid
start with this guy that was quality I
like him a lot like him a lot or them I
don't know tell us we he's we he's all
of
us he's great though and then you know
he was in Barbie so was he yeah he's one
of the Kens which one he doesn't get
like a heap ton of lines but he's he's
there in he's in like the musical number
and he's there on the beach and what's
his character name it's Ken Ken what
what let's see does he have an actual
Ken name or is he just
Ken uh who does he play he's artist Ken
there you go oh I remember artist Ken
now yeah he's a variation of beach Ken
who's far more
creative so yeah he's there he's there
there he is in this uh musical number
right
here next to Ryan Gosling and Kingsley
he's a very handsome seductive fellow
man I like see him dance yeah he's he's
a really awesome guy uh doctor dances
yeah that musical number was it felt
like a real musical I love when [__]
just randomly does musical numbers yeah
I'm about it I I wish more [__] was
musical ter it man yeah all righty well
what do you guys think leave your
thoughts down below thanks for being
with the Pat the day shout
out all right job picking name hey
Michael B Michael B my goodness Michael
B you know what man I've been seeing how
much you've been killing it on YouTube
throughout the holidays I'm wearing my
doctor who shirt right now and reason
being is cuz we are getting ready to
shoot Doctor Who we're shooting this
shout out in advance but I'm remembering
that I got a notification Bell on
Christmas day that you uploaded your
reaction to the Doctor Who Christmas
special this man's a hustler he doesn't
take any days off he's already working a
full-time job runs his channel his
YouTube Channel full whole time I'm
always bitching and complaining about
everyone who watches our videos like
tell with all you guys none of you love
me enough I hate every one of you who
watches me but Michael's like hey you
know I love everyone who watches me even
the haters and I I got to learn
something from you Michael because I see
you hustling on Christmas and I'm like
not even the Hanukkah Bear shows up for
me on Christmas oh no tell about the
Hanukkah bear he goes to the trash it's
a different video so let me remind you
about the one who the Hanukkah bear the
Hanukkah bear
goes bear goes through your trash H bear
goes through your trash he might leave
something for you he might take
something off your hands yeah and
sometimes just loose [__] in the
driveway and uh the the mystery started
when there was a a a bear going around
Colorado Springs with a with a with a
with a with a yamaka and um yeah people
call him the Hanukkah bear and that's
how the The Legend of the Hanukkah bear
came to be in
1997 so um Michael I hope that you had a
great Christmas with you and your
girlfriend obviously not cuz you spent
your time filming and editing well you
know what the b stands for is Bob
cratchet cuz you were just work into the
grindstone Christmas Day what a bob cret
you know from the classic tale of
Christmas uh Reclamation A Christmas
Carol he's have beener scrooges clock
this why I don't know about the Hanukkah
barar know I know I just been spending
all my time on these Christian Tales
missing out man it be stands also for
Bear Michael be stands for Michael Bear
now it sounds disingenuous sorry anyway
um I don't know why any of you guys
watch us but everyone of you who's
watching us should be watching Michael b
instead that's who we're going to sell
the channel to yeah take it off our
hands Michael you deal with Roxy
strier just Roxy you'll be the rang
everyone else everyone else is easy but
that freaking strier
boy yeah so you got that to look forward
to happy happy Hanukkah just in case she
sees this no everyone's a problem every
everyone even me we're all a problem
everyone's a problem all right not just
Roxy everyone is even Michael B when he
collabs with us is a problem but you
damn internet
connection Merry
[Laughter]
[Music]
Christmas